in a previous video we saw that we could
view 2/3 times 6 as whatever number is
2/3 of the way to 6 on the number line
which we saw is 4 or another way to
think about it is that 4 is 2/3 of 6 2/3
times 6 can be viewed as well what gets
me if I how many do I have if I take 2/3
of 6 now what we want to do now is apply
that same idea but 2 multiplying that a
fraction times a whole number but a
fraction times a fraction so let's say
that we wanted to take 3/4 3/4 and
multiply it by and multiply it by 1/2
and we know of course this is the exact
same thing the order that we multiply
doesn't matter this is the exact same
thing as 1/2 times 3/4 1/2 times 3/4 so
to imagine where this gets us let's draw
ourselves a number line so let's this is
0 and I'll do it pretty large so that we
have some space to work in so that's 0
and then that is 1 and of course our
line could keep on going and let's first
imagine 3/4 times 1/2 as 3/4 of the way
to 1/2 so first let's plot 1/2 on our
number line well 1/2 is literally
halfway between 0 and 1 so that's 1/2
right over there and how do we think
about 3/4 of the way to 1/2 well what we
could do is think about well what's a
fourth of 1/2 we could divide this part
of the number line into four equal
sections so that's two equal sections
now that's four equal sections and while
we're at it let's divide all of the
halves into four equal sections so let's
divide all of the halves into four equal
sections so that's four sections and now
let's do this one I'm drawing my best to
draw them equal sections so I've taken
each of the halves and I've made them
into four equal sections so this this
distance right over here this gets us or
this point right over here is 1/4 of 1/2
but that's not what we care about we
want to get to 3/4 of 1/2 so we want to
get to 1/2 3/4 of
have so this point right over here this
is literally 3/4 3/4 times 1/2 and this
is of course 1/2 year but what number is
this we can now visualize it on the
number line and let me do this in a new
color we can now visualize it on the
number line
but what number is this actually well a
big clue is is that well before we had
the the section between 0 & 1 divided it
into two equal sections when we only
have to plot 1/2 but then we took each
of those two equal sections and then
split them into 4 more sections so each
of these each of these we owe by doing
that we now essentially have divided the
section between 0 & 1 into 8 equal
sections so each of these is actually
1/8 so this point right over here is 1/8
this is two eighths and then this is 3/8
and that's that's in line with what
we've seen about multiplying fractions
before this should be equal to 3 times 1
times 1 over 4 4 times 2 4 times 2 which
is equal to 3/8 which is equal to 3/8
and everything that we're talking about
this all so we don't get confused this
is all referring to this point right
over here on the number line this point
right over here but what if we thought
about it the other way around what if we
thought about it as 1/2 of the way to
3/4 so we could divide the space between
0 & 1 into fourths let's do that
so that is 1/4 2/4 3/4 so this right
over here is the number 3/4 and we want
to go half of the way to 3/4 well what
is 1/2 of the way to 3/4 well we split
this section into two equal sections so
we could split right over there we could
split right over here and we want to go
exactly one of those sections 1/2 of 3/4
gets us once again right over here to
this point 3/8 so either way you imagine
it what
you're essentially taking 3/4 of 1/2 or
saying I'm going to go 3/4 of the way to
1/2 or you say I'm going to go 1/2 of
the way to 3/4 either way
hopefully it now makes conceptual sense
you can visualize it and it makes
numeric sense this is going to be equal
to 3/8